let's go to Alon from Boston who has
called in before and has had some
disagreements with me what's going on
Elan Elan you might have us muted
because we can't hear you but you are on
if you unmute we might be able to hear
you otherwise I'll have to move on hello
this me that's you oh I don't know what
you heard last time I called him a name
but my name is Eli Eli I heard Alon okay
we will correct sorry
the my phone doesn't have the best
microphone anyway I got a quick question
and it's not about disagreements well
I'm not here to call you out this time
no good put it that way huh
so I've noticed that some people
commenting on your YouTube videos claim
that some of your views on foreign
policy or maybe specifically Israel are
more to the right of most progressives
but they aren't usually backed up or
source they don't like usually have a
link to another video where you talk
about it are these guys just trolling to
make me think that you're you know on
the opposition of some of what
progressives believe or do they have a
point what do you what do you think
about that well I would just say point
to the policy right I mean point point
to the policy or or even now that you're
on the phone with me Eli asked me a
particular policy question because it's
sort of like it you know I don't know
what we gain by saying here's people
labeling you do you accept or deny the
label really it's all policy right so
like let's drill down what would be a
policy question well I guess
specifically what are your thoughts on
the Israeli government's treatment of
pills and Palestinians and and the Gaza
Strip and and what's going on there
you're saying aren't so okay are you
talking about the Netanyahu
administration specifically and what
they've done or do you mean the broader
security of Israel specifically
Netanyahu yeah I mean I'm I'm against
Benjamin Netanyahu I don't support
Benjamin Netanyahu he's a right winger
he is in bed and in a coalition with
some of the most extreme religious right
elements of is Israeli govern
and I think that not only has he made no
strides toward peace I don't even have
any reason to think for a second that he
has anything any interest in doing that
because he doesn't have anything to gain
if there are serious peace negotiations
he benefits and we've seen from the
election games he's played with security
games he benefits from people being in a
state of mind where they want the most
extreme sort of right-wing aggression
from the Israeli government so I oppose
Benjamin Netanyahu's administration
thank you I can ask one quick other
question unrelated sure so I saw a video
the other day I have a woman who called
in wanting to talk about some billions
of dollars in fraud that was happening
by some financial institution did yeah
it was it was a sad call yeah did you
ever follow up by email or something no
I mean I said she could email me the
stuff if she wanted to but but she
didn't and you know the the sort of
consensus was that that that's someone
who's dealing with some emotional issues
you know well I hope she's all right
thank you for all right Eli we will get
your name corrected in the caller ID Eli
not Alon thank you for the correction